we're going to stop that's going to be
where we begin tonight to began very
simply not just for numbers but if you
are have this list just like I do you
can put a parable that makes begin like
what would people interested in all of
this in a beginning with a simple thing
counting all that began with I have
young children and they learn to count
very very early like 1 2 3 some of our
very first words that we learn you know
in an airport that's like one car two
cars three cars my son is two loves that
kind of thing right and so this begins
very early everyone's interested we come
today like how many of this do I have
how many of this do I need very welcome
in fact counting so relevant that we
have this word which you might think
relates to but it's the word calculate
it's a very mathematical word where it
comes from is from counting stones
people used to have these little rocks
that they used to count everyone seen an
abacus before and it's like there's got
this look what you can even yeah great
fantastic human left and right to help
you count okay so calculate is about
these cutting stones in fact there's a
word and we're into modeling room to
show you but there's with all of you
learn that has the same basis as this
one is the word chalk chalk you wouldn't
see a piece of talk before right
and it's basically yeah excellent it's
just a kind of rock really it's like so
it's ground up and it's the same kind of
idea but counting stones are rare
numbers we
it's very familiar now numbers strange
things right if you try and understand
so I got something said this than last
well you try to understand the patterns
there there are so many little things
that are surprising and unusual there
I'm just going to show you a couple to
introduce you to what I mean by
mathematical thinking and then we're
going to dive into some work today so
I'm going to go with this idea of our
counting stones as a little space you
can just write this right underneath you
okay I want you to think about you might
need to do a bit of torii if you have
pencils color pencils even that we
really didn't is I only have a few
boring colors all to the best that I can
if you think about all the numbers one
to ten just think about who for a second
okay
now I want you to imagine that you're
working with them is counting stones so
for instance I could put in five you for
the example I could put three stones and
I can arrange them in a whole bunch of
different ways I could put them like in
an enemy you draw some stones with me
like that you sort of randomly seen
there I could put them in a line that's
sort of nice but you can't really see
much here is not much it's interesting
right
one of the words that also comes to mind
there's no is questions what do people
think that mathematics is about answers
we will find answers lots and lots of
them
the much more interesting is can you
take a number can you push it questions
try to work out tell me something about
yourself
can you can I understand so for instance
there was three you might like to draw a
different number of on there were
counting stones on your pity he's the
first question I want to ask you right
can you take any number you like from
one to ten you just wanna make you small
so you might be
any number from one to ten and put them
into two rows can you do that with the
draw and number and put the counting
stones into two rows any way you like
can you do that try and draw picking
them up figure them up anything for one
cent and just draw it out Steve Rose I'm
gonna do with three
okay so here my two rows right I don't
know if you look Scylla or different to
mine maybe you could want to bend out
here make your space in the flowerpot
okay
what I noticed is I've got these two the
kind of pair up I'll try to get them to
two birds right
so for instance I can say hey look these
are paired up right yeah sort of buddies
of each other but then you got this guy
it's kind of bit sad I'm ugly
it's got no one hanging out with you
right keep that thought in your head
draw another number
okay how many of you true an odd number
yeah
how much can someone give me a different
other bedroom yeah six six okay who got
number that's okay who gave who did do
it on down I'll get to six in a minute
yeah what did you do seven okay I'm
gonna be seven maybe you didn't do seven
you can drop me as well
so again you can see I've got my two
brothers right
and again just like with three if I want
them to buddy up you guys get to do
drama I like one less than a fortnight
maybe you can see these guys buddy up
that's really nice but then now this is
the whole point for one week all these
odd numbers because can you see and if
you teared up three at 571 d9 is always
that guy and he's the house now the
other one half exactly right if I could
love you to write that bear with me one
of the things that you will discover is
that every single word every single
piece of language that you will learn in
that Mattox there's reason for it odd
numbers not just called odd numbers
because they're weird or strange because
just like here isn't all about now
there's another kind of number having
names yet if they're not bored what do
we call them yeah we call them even now
was reading it you guys were not even
done for a long time I think is don't
shout it out big first
even numbers so never said something
what do you reckon
they all pair up they all match up
evenly right like if I say okay I want
to over to right here I want to UM line
up things and I want them to be sort of
head out with each other and look they
even you guys are very even almost right
paired up with an odd number today right
it's what overlap but everyone else even
so you see these words right
they have meanings and they show us
something at how these members behave
too bit about their personality so now
that was all simple let's do some
operations with these numbers I want to
show you an unusual pattern and I want
you to keep these counting stones in the
back of your head okay this next bit
because if you've got more than one
color would be really useful first ago I
just want you to write down there these
are pattern one what's 42 plus this is
the next odd number right that's what I
was thinking that one for story of
course is that's good okay if I wanted
to extend that pattern what do you think
would be the next line that I write give
me kids starts with one plus three yeah
ooh hold on so I'm trying to I'm trying
to prove a pattern right and see what
happens next you're like whoa okay okay
I am there Hannah no but because you can
see I'm having lots of things I'm trying
to think about these odd numbers that
I'm interesting in for a particular
reason
yeah I was fine there by the way I
should say I could have added possible
we're just really what mustard seeds for
and those are good all be fine right
I'm interested in something particular
there and you'll see why in a second one
plus three all right okay so when you
add five what do you get I get a cup and
then one more will give me it was very
close I'm going to do this one more time
at a fourth row and I wonder if you
notice anything unusual
okay so this time reduce lines so
numbers are getting a bit bigger cuz I
already know these ones are all going to
nine and seven more to that I'm gonna
get sixty very good okay I'm gonna pause
hmm we saw is odd numbers here I'll be
right with you can't respond and we saw
okay that's why they come on no big deal
that's fine that's less there's
something weeds going on just combine
them it's going on right okay so each
time it's go how about our numbers you
can see that to get there cuz I add one
odd number every time I can yeah what
did you say that is
every time and then if you ask the when
it's or if you plus it all you need to
do is add one line and don't do that
it's the same way it's okay you sort of
happened you saw you think you had
double and then add one that's
interesting but they didn't keep going
now I'm gonna pause you're saying yeah
that it's okay I'm so glad lots of your
best to new ideas sometimes you know how
to talk that supportive is right I think
some of you see by now because we had a
bit of time you see something but not
everyone's there you one four nine and
sixteen these numbers that I'm in deal
with in here the kind of special numbers
there are being unusually honor if
anyone can see if I draw join this and
this don't you see what's going on yeah
wait why is not number positive number
so firstly I could get this is
alternating pain in fact I don't even
know what the next one is yeah but I
know it's going to be an ordinal long
because this one was even right okay ah
yeah this is all the usual things we
don't disclose this is the most unusual
thing and I'm trying to help you see it
this is a square right and here's
another square it's two by two you see
to display through that way and that's
why I have one two three four spots do
you notice that I can draw the next one
so can you in fact just rule that swear
beside it one by one and then two by two
and then three my pain
getting these squeeze in here now the
last one I think it's probably big
enough deciding to get a bid on bid on
many you saw me throw this my question
to you is why is it doing that's kind of
weed
what is this number no I said you know
it's kind of have a personality in every
single one
what is this mother behaving like why
why are each of these doing